there's a class action complaint uh
in the state of california against uh
state agencies in california
who are using crt who are using critical
race theory and this was sent
to us by one of uh one of our viewers um
which i'm
i am grateful um let's see i want to
read
you can show my show my screen here zach
i'm going to read a couple paragraphs
and
um and then a couple more after that so
this is
just this is from october 13th 2020 so
just a few months ago
just to set us up here this class action
seeks to eliminate discriminatory
policies in customs and california state
agencies
that institutionalize racial preferences
in connection with recruiting hiring
other conditions of employment
and which overtly treat people as racial
categories rather than individuals
defendants wade crowfoot and charlton
bonham collectively the defendants
who were acting secretary for the
california natural resources agency
and director for the california
department department of fish and
wildlife respectively
have implemented policies and customs
that are steeped in critical race theory
a branch of post-modern academic theory
which promotes invidious race
discrimination
so just just a pause here for a moment
the california department of wildlife
and the natural resources agency they're
this is now
in places uh where you know
even many of us who have been well aware
of this would have thought
like these agencies should have been
most immune for the longest right like
this is these are actually agencies
that are doing that are that are dealing
with real things out there in the world
that aren't social constructs
um later in the piece um the
the complaint specifies first crow foot
and the speakers engage in the selection
bias of isolated incidents as proof of
systemic racism
so they're doing this little sleight of
hand where they say there's a thing that
happened
therefore everything is racist and
systemic racism is everywhere
um and second crow foot and the speakers
then argue that any disparate outcomes
in society
must be the result of white supremacy
again it's like you know
it feels like a similar point but it's a
little bit different that
any disparate outcomes like any time
you've got differential outcomes
the only possible hypothesis to explain
that is white supremacy so this is
anti-logic anti-science anti-everything
good frankly um and then just one
more section um that i want to read from
here um
if i can find it okay zac you can show
my screening if you like
on page 12. paragraphs 4748
uh and i will i will post this in the
show notes the substance of the program
follows so this is with regard to a
program
uh that uh one of the defendants has
used in his agency
uh with with his employees the substance
of the program follows a similar pattern
bonham and his guests conclude without
any evidence that the reason they do not
see people at recreating in proportion
to their population
is entirely due to white racism and that
they would implement quotas and state
agencies to assure
racial equity in who chooses to use
california's outdoor spaces
the conversation begins with a
conjectural claim that black people do
not frequent california's outdoor spaces
in proportion to their population
due to white supremacy and quote
generational trauma
bottom discusses the idea that bad
things happening in the woods and quote
approximately a hundred years ago in the
jim crow south has led black individuals
today to believe that quote
being around trees is unsafe
my goodness my goodness yes and in fact
we have
so again sophistry and really
that is the central concept to so much
of this so many of these claims are
transparently nonsense
um you know we have been talking about
the
obvious sophistry in the idea that if
there is a discrepancy in the number of
people relative to their
representation of the population that
that must inherently be the result
of a bias we've been talking about that
explicitly since the damore memo
right where damore's point was
effectively yes it could be that but
that's not the only explanation that
would generate the pattern
it's obviously true it should take any
room of
four smart people approximately three
minutes to establish
this to a fairly well and yet years down
the road we are still talking about it
are we not scientists right are we not
capable i mean
even if you can't think of the proof
yourself right just simply having heard
it once
ought to reveal oh yeah there are other
things that could cause the pattern
therefore it does not necessarily imply
it right
um so you know the question is why is
this stuff so
sticky in these cases we have talked
on this program extensively
about the fact that differential use of
for example
bike paths or nature areas does not and
in fact
cannot plausibly be the result of white
supremacy right nobody's keeping anybody
out of the bike lane
so the point is if you go and you
measure who passes you
in the bike lane and it turns out that
there's a racial disparity
it may be the result of something it may
be the result
of what neighborhood different races
live in and therefore how pleasant it is
to bike or how safe
or something like that but it cannot be
that the bike lane itself has any bias
right and you know historically i can
put together an argument historically
as you know after the civil war uh
and uh black people were moving north um
that they would have been more likely to
choose urban centers and we in fact know
that this did happen and why
because people in urban areas
who had less exposure to people who
looked different from them
might have been more likely to cause to
bring grief
to the black people and so people
migrating
out of the enslaved south might well
have chosen to be in cities and so at
this point there may be generations
within black american families
of city life and far less exposure to
um to some of this other stuff and that
doesn't mean again
that nature is racist or that the
choices that those people were making
um were um you know
that there was anything wrong with them
even though they may well have been
making those choices in part due to an
understanding
that i think was probably correct that
it would be safer to move to say chicago
in 1880 as a black person than to
uh southern you know farmland illinois
probably
let's put it this way there are dozens
of impacts right it may be a matter
of you know where there was likely to be
work
and how easy it is to commute and there
are dozens of things that may indeed
be the result of past racism and past
white supremacy and the problem is that
people want to import some pattern that
is differential that may in fact have
something to do with racism that may
have existed
100 200 years ago and they want to say
therefore
it means that that racism exists today
which then results in them
leveling an accusation at people you are
definitely racist because you're white
right that is not a logical conclusion
from
the bias no matter how much racism
played into the original
uh discrepancy that we now see manifest
and so
how much better would the conversation
be if we were actually talking about how
these past patterns that yes indeed were
rooted in racism
have impacts that carry through today
without it functioning
through the bias of people right which
isn't to say biased people don't exist
but it is to say you cannot do this
candy thing where you just simply assert
oh well if you're not actively
anti-racist by this
you know list of criteria here then we
know what you are right you're part of
the problem no that's not the way it
works
and yet and yet he can well he can
so there is a there is a question that i
still do not have a good
grasp on beyond this sort of like the
left is ever more gullible
like why has it been so widely accepted
why is it getting so much traction why
is there a freaking
class action lawsuit in california
against the directors of the
these agencies whose uh presumably
raison d'etre is about
uh protecting the land i mean like this
this is the last place where crt belongs
and here it is
and i'm grateful to the people who have
initiated this class action lawsuit but
this is you know this is a one one
example in a sea of many
and um of all of those examples of
people actually saying i've had enough
i'm pushing back this is ridiculous
um those reflect a tiny minority of the
actual situations where no one is yet
publicly pushing back so they don't know
how to they're disempowered like
whatever it is
well let's try to answer that question
because i think it's hard to say
what precisely the answer is but in a
general sense it's fairly clear
and i must say i've been frustrated
by the degree to which people focus on
what they call cancel culture
right i feel like there are a lot of
things that are relevant
to our circumstance free speech
questions cancer culture etc but the
the focus on them is wrong and really i
think the answer to the question you
pose
is that the reason that people have
fallen prey
to these um obvious uh
sophistry constructions
softest constructions is that
there is a penalty there is a the
equivalent of
online brown shirts and their purpose
is to beat the crap out of you if you
show an
instinct towards rejecting these things
or questioning them or deploying logic
where they don't want it deployed
and so in essence what we're seeing is
not that
people are endogenously so gullible
it's that in the context of a threat if
you show
signs of skepticism what happens is
people stop
doing that and what it looks like is
yeah people are accepting this obvious
nonsense
and the fact is look come on how hard
would it be to sell the population on
the idea
that there is no sexual binary it would
be almost impossible if there weren't a
threat
attached to it right everybody knows
this because it's so central to all of
our lives
irrespective every single human who has
ever lived knows
right everybody knows this right yeah
so uh that's interesting and i do think
um that the timing the rise of
of so-called cancel culture and i say
so-called not because i don't believe in
it but just because as you say you know
i don't
i don't think it's an expansive enough
term um
but you know it we began to see this
really happening at evergreen in sort of
you know beginning like 2013 2014
that's exactly the moment that like john
height and greg lukianov talk about
incarnally up the american mind
as things beginning to change on college
campuses and so i do think that your
answer
um you know i you know i've talked about
a perfect storm
having to do with three things and
actually um heightened lucky one i've
talked about a couple of these things as
well but you know
what you're pointing to basically is um
the increasing ubiquity of social
media allowed for pylons
such that you can increase the
gullibility of people in real time
because they're afraid of the virtual
pylons
but and then the other pieces of the
perfect storm include
the widespread um drugging of the
children
excuse me um with um with
anti-anxiety anti-psychotic
antidepressants
and then exogenous hormones and you know
all of these things
and then a parenting style that um that
doesn't allow children to take risk and
and explore who they are um but the
social media thing is what really
you know what really was happening in
exactly that
that moment but i don't think it goes
back far enough so what we what that
doesn't explain
is why when when we were in college
in the late 80s early 90s we saw we saw
this postmortem and we pushed back
against
it and it looked and in fact i found you
know my i think it was my senior thesis
i wrote into the beginning like i'm
seeing some of this
some of this nutsy nutty stuff
in the literature and it's fringe
and i don't think it'll go anywhere but
i do think it bears mentioning that this
is one way that people are thinking
um about um my thesis was on actually
how
how it is that um in non-human primates
females establish
friendships and what those friendships
look like and to some degree also how
testosterone is mitigating those
relationships
and there was already some of this like
social constructionist stuff in
in that because anthropology got taken
over pretty early
and i then really thought that
um even though we saw little glimmers of
it in grad school
and we laughed about it and pushed back
against it in little ways
that there was no way that it would grow
and that it would become so all-powerful
i didn't i did not predict as much even
though we saw it and we pushed back
against
particular instantiations that we ran
into i did not see
the last several years coming well so i
want to
make this into a model because i agree i
didn't see it coming
like this right we knew the danger of it
but i would never have predicted the
absurdity of some of the things that are
now
accepted as self-evident
but so there's a question about what
context you exist in
and what my claim is going to be is that
when people
start to espouse
nonsensical beliefs as if they were
self-evident
there will be an analog to brown shirts
right the point is the two things are
not separate
so to the extent that you walk into a
context where people are saying
crazy things where's the enforcement
mechanism well
in an anthropology in a cultural
anthropology department in the 90s the
enforcement mechanism is
you're not welcome in this department
unless you agree to these things we have
the ability not to admit you
and we have the ability to toss you out
um on your ear
if you if we miss you on the first pass
and then it turns out that you're a
skeptic
the numbers were so small that all it
took was one social constructionist
post-modernist post-structuralist in an
apartment
to potentially fairly quickly change the
culture of the department
right and the point is the department is
built to be exclusive and so
excluding people is not hard well but my
point is
departments were busy excluding nonsense
until suddenly they were excluding
everything but the nonsense right so
like that that requires an explanation
of when that what that flip is
well i would argue we see in a million
different contexts
some sort of institution public or
private that
gets taken over by somebody who knows
how to play office politics and
transitions to my earlier point that
because because departments tend to be
small in terms of number of faculty
all it really takes is one person who's
who's
got this as their mission and um they
can affect
change in a way that they never could in
a larger you know they'd be drowned out
they're just
they'd be they'd be too diluted right
diluted in addition to being
diluted um in in a larger population
so in the case of the um the
what we heard in anthropology
departments in the 90s that thing
then made it into the wider world and so
the point that we should
uh have for foremost in our minds is
well for that to have happened
we now need an enforcement mechanism
that mirrors what takes place
in an academic department that explains
the wider context
and so my point would be okay what is
that in this context
it's uh largely um the
unpersoning that can happen to you
online if you show a certain kind of
skepticism and
as proof of concept the intermediate
thing
remember back when evergreen was
supposed to be an anomaly and it wasn't
going to
it didn't matter it was just college
kids overreacting well i was just
looking at benjamin voices
most recent his 23rd episode of his
evergreen
documentary is prolific yeah and amazing
prolific and amazing and
uh i think as a result almost entirely
of his
work this is in some ways the most
thoroughly
documented historical event um at least
you know that i've encountered right the
level
of minute by minute that he's captured
is incredible but
you know he uses in this most recent
video
he juxtaposes um people
saying things with video of them same
people doing things in a different
context and so one of the things he has
is jamil
who was paid by the college to help
rewrite the activists
this is essentially the lead activist
the one who organized the kidnapping of
administrators
and apparently sent people to my
classroom to protest me and all of that
um after invoking privately on his
facebook page the idea that it would be
great to have
white people face witch hunts but anyway
this guy
was hired by the college to help rewrite
the student code of conduct which he had
violated
later the summer following um and
benjamin points to this video there's a
video clip of him
and his clique walking around like and
he's flipping a baseball bat and it's
very you know
clockwork orange kind of craziness right
but the point is okay people are saying
crazy stuff on this campus
where are the brown shirts oh right
caught on video
um so that's the question is every time
you have people
claiming to believe things that no sound
no reasonable person could possibly
believe there will be an enforcement
mechanism
and you may not have put the two
together but that's what's going on